[Music]
my name's Fiona May but in court
it's my lady I'm always too busy the law
can take over your life you're coming to
bed mm it's tomorrow the case okay bye
lady they're ready for you
rise fee shall we talk excuse me
long day I don't know how to say this I
think I think I want to have an affair
what I love you
we're meant to be together but we don't
even kiss anymore
yeah we have an urgent case m'lady the
applicant Adam has leukemia however the
boy and his parents are Jehovah's
Witnesses and it's contrary to their
faith to accept blood into their system
I would like to hear from Adam himself
you've come to change your mind
why is a blood transfusion wrong why is
anything wrong tortured dying being
unfaithful in your marriage what is the
point of your silence
people think you've been influenced by
your parents somehow I've got to decide
the child's welfare shall be the courts
paramount consideration life is more
precious and dignity do you remember how
we were don't you miss that
[Music]
my lady I've got so many questions for
you thank you for me closer something my
delicious adventure she talked to me
this young man I'm sure she could answer
all his questions but he's dying
it's just a time lovely boy
remember all of life and love
is a day of anguish at the world Courts
of Justice
Our Lady they're ready for you
[Music]
you
you